Hi everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters.
In this presentation we're going to talk about my five favorite
nutraceuticals or really the overall treatments for cancer and
as much as I actually made this presentation it's really hard for me to pick
five favorites because everybody is so different and these are the most five
common things that we use but these are really my five favorites when we talk
about different cancer therapy and things that I think that have changed
cancer therapy for the better in the last 100 years or 50 years so here we go
five favorite things for cancer number one would be or I'm going five four three two
one right so my fifth favorite thing is painkriotic enzymes painkriotic enzymes was
really started back in the early 1900s by Dr. Bard and then it was it was kind of
buried by chemotherapy treatment it wasn't used for a long time until Dr. William
Kelly himself an orthodontist got cancer the liver and the painkrius and he
searched it through at that time there was no Google but he went to the local
medical school dug through the archives found Dr. Bard's work on using painkriotic
enzymes also found Dr. Gershin's work about using dietary changes and that's
what he did for himself high dose painkriotic enzymes and he basically cured
himself if you want us to talk about cure but he managed his cancer for he was
given I think three months to live and I think he lived another 27 years so painkriotic
enzymes can be fantastic they can help break down the cancer so you're not
taking the enzymes typically you take enzymes dietary enzymes to break down food to
help you digest your food painkriotic enzymes today are sold for that purpose to help
you break down food so that it could be properly absorbed your digest helping the
digested process but in this case you're taking high doses between meals in order
for you to absorb those so it could help digest really gobble up the acidic
slime layer and that there's a road to cancer to allow your immune system to help
attack it that's partly what the right machine does but painkriotic enzymes can be
super super helpful for that so very thankful for those number four
layatril layatril was really big in this late 60s and 70s I believe was
outlawed in the United States but you cannot argue with the fact that thousands of
people have had their life hugely extended by the use of layatril layatril is one
of probably the one of the more common things that we suggest and it works it works
phenomenal now understand we're talking about these five favorites and if you read
by book stop fighting cancer it's available as a free download on our website
there you'll you could easily make the mistake by taking too many things so I'm
going to hit these five favorites and I'm going to take all of them but I'm going to
take this and that the other thing from from got your cutters book because I read
his book and don't make that mistake so in real life our patients we test them
out all these things so literally they're just a couple things most of them so if
you're on too many things it can be really it can overwhelm your liver you if
you too much of a good thing it's a bad thing and you have to detox this so don't
don't make that error layatril though is what hugely beneficial thing and we
just see miracles with layatril so nobody could tell me otherwise SCAC T is
another one of those things that's my third favorite SCAC T was named after
Radeh Cassie or however you pronounce her name she was a nurse that cured her
mother in the early 1920s I believe who had stage 4 cancer and with this T that was
an old Ojibwe recipe she was a Canadian and got it actually the recipe from
Ojibwe chief who when he gave her the recipe he made her promise that he would she would
only give it away it would not sell it to the pharmaceutical companies who were after him
for the recipe at the time he just refused to do that he thought that was a moral
just a slap against everything that he believed in and everything that he was taught
in his culture well Radeh gave away her care in a clinic she was a nurse gave away her care
the clinic in a candidate for decades before she was finally shut down thousands and thousands
of people have been helped with SCAC T it is just another one of those things it's an herbal
concussion of just different herbs and it has been a miracle for a lot of people it's just really
been a blessing my second favorite thing certainly we just talk about favorites is medicinal
mushrooms now this is our blended medicinal mushrooms simply because we just couldn't find everything
that I wanted it a blend that didn't cost the patients a fortune so we actually by organic
documented organic mixing up ourselves and sell it to our patient members and sell it a cost
just so that it's so it's just our our desire is just to is to help people at the lowest cost possible
so I just struggle if a person's taking five six seven you know I've had some people come in and
they were taken over a thousand dollars a month in supplements so it's just it's just ridiculous so
we try to keep things at cost especially all our kids are cure type things as much as we possibly can
medicinal mushrooms are a huge thing that's this probably what we have most of our
I would say the majority of our patients out of all the things that we use we use medicinal
mushrooms the most even though there's a hundred things that we use and it splits up as we test them
we only use what that person needs but medicinal mushrooms comes up more commonly than anything else
and maybe it's just what we have in there because it's it's a huge there's at least a dozen or
so things in there so I really like that we've seen phenomenal results with that not just with cancer
but with H. Pylori and some other things it's been a huge blessing and my favorite thing for cancer
is certainly the rife machine so we've been asked oh I can't tell you how many times that we get
calls because people are read by book and they they want to do our program but they don't want to
spend the money on a rife machine and it is tempting to say we want to help these people but
we just really have to pray about whether it's the right thing to do because we really believe
God let us stone this road and using a rife machine and it's been a huge blessing for people we've
just seen too many people that had you know two weeks to two months to live that lived you know
that are either still alive today several years later or that lived several years because of
the way we directed them and we don't take any credit for that but God has really used the rife
machine and some different things in our practice to really be a blessing now again you got to
remember done at these are miracles you know in themselves and I don't be that that God can't use
these things but I'm just saying I don't want anybody just to think oh they're going to get a
rife machine and they're going to be cured of cancer just doesn't work that way these are all tools
and if you don't have the healing ability in your own body nothing's going to work so
you you have to use a tool and use a tool wisely like anything else and it could be a huge blessing
but we've just seen so many so many great things with the rife machine we just can't leave that out
again this is like five favorites but there's so many things that we do if you have any questions
call our office if you have not been to our website I have tons of videos just like this on our website
a lot of information I publish a blog several times a week a newsletter at least once a week
or what a couple times a month with more information at it we really want to educate
the public we know that not everybody could come to us and if the more we could help people
through education the better all right I hope this is a blessing thanks so much